[Music]
hey what's up mkbhd here and this
this is the best android tablet out
right now and it looks like it's from
the future or something like if you show
this to someone 15 years ago they would
think it's impossible i guess it's
impossibly thin 1.6 pound powerful
medium machine with speakers that
somehow fill a room a massive battery
and an entire desktop computer interface
inside i mean it's so thin you'd swear
you could just snap it in half super
easily which i'm not going to try it but
someone keep this thing away from zach
so this is the galaxy tab s8 ultra so
yes there is a galaxy tab s8 and a tab
s8 plus both of them far more reasonable
far less expensive and most importantly
smaller but you know what there's a real
interest in huge tablets like this mega
tablets because there is an actual
benefit to tablets that are this big i
would know because i've been using this
one and the benefits of this massive
nearly 15 inch screen are for media
watching gaming multitasking and of
course the huge canvas for the stylist
they're all very real there are also
some real drawbacks though so if you are
one of the many people who have been
tweeting at me asking about this thing
wondering if it's a legit ipad pro
alternative well this is everything you
need to know so really the number one
standout piece of this tablet is the
top-notch display sorry i had to we'll
get there but the screen is just awesome
and there's a bunch of things that
combine to make it probably the most
impressive i've ever seen in a tablet
number one is just of course the sheer
size of it
14.6 inches diagonally which definitely
suits the ultra name it's got these thin
symmetrical bezels all the way around
aside from the dual cameras now we're
working with a 16 by 10 aspect ratio at
2960 by 1848 resolution which sounds
really high in person it's not the
sharpest thing i've ever seen just
because it's so huge so it checks out to
about 240 ppi and if you get close
enough with this pixel arrangement you
can actually start to see the soft edges
of some text and icons and things like
that but it's definitely not a problem
at all for normal viewing distances and
then it's oled so i think this is the
largest oled touchscreen i've ever used
we all know about the mini led displays
and some laptops and even the ipad pro
with their tons of local dimming zones
but this is a full size basically laptop
size screen where every individual pixel
lights itself so you're getting those
pitch black inky blacks you're getting
an incredible contrast ratio and
watching videos that take advantage of
it are very impressive there's also an
optical fingerprint reader underneath
the display on the right hand side
the only thing really that's not world
class about this display honestly is
that it's not ltpo it's just 120 hertz
all the time and the max brightness it
maxes out at 380 nits which is actually
totally reasonable inside but it's not
actually doing much if you go out in the
sun if you're the type of person to use
a tablet in your window so that's just
something to keep in mind just for
context the m1 ipad pro gets up to 600
nits and the s22 ultra the phone i just
reviewed gets up to 1750 nits but you
know that's a phone you use outside so
let's talk about the notch then right so
huge display up at the top in the middle
there's this little tiny notch with two
cameras in it that's two 12 megapixel 4k
webcams one regular and one ultra wide
they're both too big to fit in the thin
bezels that they fitted all the way
around the tablet so it punches in a
little bit they put this little notch up
here
it's tiny it's way smaller than the
iphone's notch and in a display that's
way bigger
honestly it doesn't bother me at all you
use the screen for three seconds and it
disappears to your eye and you forget
about it now is there a hilarious irony
that this is the same company that made
these commercials making fun of the
notch every chance they got and now
they're the first to put a notch on
their tablet yeah absolutely that's
really funny but i don't actually mind
it here what i will say is they did put
them in the right place which is on the
horizontal long side of the bezel
because this is a tablet that's
basically meant to be used horizontally
all the time you know an ipad maybe you
can argue sometimes you use it in
portrait like a notebook and a clipboard
sometimes in landscape this one feels
pretty ridiculous holding it vertical
and i think samsung knows it's going to
be horizontal a lot with this aspect
ratio and so they put the webcam
on the top and the fingerprint reader
over there on the side is easily
reachable with your thumb it's great and
then dave2d said something really
interesting really smart in his video
which is
we don't actually usually hold these
huge tablets while we're using them like
sometimes you do sure maybe you're
leaning back on the couch holding it up
watching a video maybe typing something
out real quick but actually most of the
time we're using a tablet we're sitting
it down somewhere it's like propped up
or it's in a folio case i don't think my
ipad pro has left its folio case in like
a year just because i prop it up all the
time and so there is a book cover case
available for the s8 ultra
but it costs
350 dollars
so there's your kickstand get to prop it
up
watch stuff but
this plus the keyboard
three hundred and fifty dollars so i've
been using this total at least fourteen
hundred fifty dollar package for about a
week and it's great honestly it's great
the performance and animations have been
consistent it's amazing for media
consumption youtube netflix games that
is not a surprise what's interesting is
the snapdragon 8gen one in here it turns
out it's actually underclocked a little
bit this actually benchmarks lower than
phones running the same chip but i'm
telling you that's because a phone is
eight millimeters thick and it can
actually fit a new cooling solution for
this hot new chip
this tablet is too thin and can't fit
that so this tablet will get a little
bit warm and under clock a little bit so
then the battery life
is okay so it has it has a surprisingly
large 11 200 milliamp hour battery in
here despite being so thin
but it also has a huge screen so evens
out i was getting about eight hours of
screen on time on a heavy day which is a
bit more than a really good phone but
you definitely do still have to charge
it at the end of a heavy day if you use
it a lot but if you use it occasionally
you know the standby time is excellent
it can last you several days i just have
a feeling if you're spending this much
on a tablet convertible thing you're
going to want to actually get a lot of
use out of it so we're probably already
fully entrenched in the what is a
computer conversation so this computer
is very much still
a large android tablet so that means it
has all the pros and cons of every other
android tablet meaning there's still no
instagram app that scales properly my
to-do list app tick tick doesn't really
take advantage of the whole screen
soundcloud doesn't work there's lots of
apps that don't look amazing on this
huge screen because
that's the way it is with android
tablets and that's on the developers yes
but that's a pretty consistent android
tablet thing but you know what there's
one way you could say is maybe a way
around it
and that is samsung's dex so dex is
samsung's desktop ui that's built into a
lot of their devices so if you were to
plug into a keyboard and a monitor or in
this case the book cover keyboard and
hit the shortcut key it switches you
into dex mode which kind of feels like a
chromebook so you've got a dock at the
bottom that actually matches what you
had in tablet mode plus a windowed ui
now that lets you multitask and move
things around you can do file management
and treat it a lot more like a real
computer or at least the chromebook so
the trackpad is decent it's just overall
a next level of versatility that makes
this thing way more useful if you are
trying to turn it into your primary
computer you can also change the opacity
of windows for some reason it's great
it's definitely not perfect though
there's plenty of apps that don't play
well with the scaling the whole system
still has the same problem too that the
ipad has which is it's very top-heavy
all of the weight is in the tablet and
it's genuinely difficult to use it on
your lap like a normal laptop but i
still say this this is clearly better
than the ipad's attempt at being a
computer it does a lot of things better
it does the floating window support way
better than the ipad ever has it has a
micro sd card slot which the ipad has
never had and it also has the cameras
horizontally in the right place and in
much better quality than the ipad so for
video calls or recording videos with the
front facing cameras these cameras are
actually really good the ultra wide
camera even has auto framing although
it's not nearly as responsive or smooth
as the ipad pro and it cuts down to
1080p in this mode but at least it looks
like you're looking at the person you're
talking to on a zoom call and then last
but not least
drawing stuff now i'm not even going to
pretend to be an artist who can take
advantage of the differences between
this and the apple pencil versus others
but here are some things that i
definitely did notice so number one this
pen still charges on the back of the
tablet here in only this specific
orientation which is kind of easy to
scrape off and and get knocked off if
you move around too much which is
unfortunate but what's funny is they did
make a case this book cover case and you
can see it has a little indentation here
so if you slap it on the back it
actually holds the pen
in place if you align everything just
right so it's charging and can be
accessed like that cool the other thing
is it actually does now attach
magnetically to the top
but it doesn't charge there so that's a
good place to leave it temporarily i
guess if you're going back and forth
between using it and not using it but
yeah if it doesn't charge there don't
forget about it at least you have the
option then number two this pen is
actually included with this tablet so
you can mess around with it if you want
to you're kind of encouraged to play
around with it and try stuff the
features pop up and just make themselves
known whenever you pull the tablet off
of the back of the thing but you know
it's really good at just drawing and
sketching and things like that the palm
rejection with these tiny bezels is good
enough that i don't have to think about
it and it has lightning quick basically
real-time 2.8 millisecond response times
that make it feel like real paper remote
controlled air actions are still here
samsung notes is as powerful as ever
with the handwriting recognition and pen
up is also included for you know more
digital drawing type stuff and it's good
you know i'll defer to some actual
digital artists to make the call on
whether it's actually better than other
options out there in their reviews but i
like this overall package and then bonus
points the tab s8 ultra has the second
best speakers i've ever heard in the
tablet right behind the larger ipad pro
but it's got all this space so it's got
this huge quad speaker setup dolby atmos
support
very loud
not quite as full and bassy as the ipad
pro but easily fills a room plenty for
watching movies and videos and things
like that really good speaker setup so
if it sounds like i like this tablet a
lot
because i do i really like this i think
this is the best android tablet out
right now um and it's even gonna be
getting better they said they're gonna
add they're they're working on adding
lumafusion to the galaxy store which is
that video editing app on tablets which
could make it even more powerful so then
do i recommend it
well
you gotta know what you want and if you
were looking for a tablet that actually
fits the ultra name this is the first
one that actually does it the huge
screen is kind of unrivaled than any
other tablet
and then it's so capable with decks and
with all this other stuff they've built
in that it's actually genuinely one of
the most versatile computers
you can get
so that's been it thanks for watching
catch you guys the next one
peace
[Music]